recalls for a captive seaworld killer
well to be freed into the wild after
activists filmed her beaching herself at
the side of her pool at a Tenerife
tourist park the Orca called morgan was
left at laura park almost motionless for
around ten minutes at the end of the
show as tourists reportedly stopped to
take selfies with her the clip filmed by
anonymously bite morgan monitors was
posted onto the website of the dolphin
project which campaigns against animal
cruelty joining us now from washington
is jeffrey venture doctor and former
trainer at SeaWorld hello to you friend
of the show of course we've spoken many
times in the past - what would have been
happening to this ocker at the time
how would she what how would she have
been feeling well you know it's obvious
by looking at the videotape that Morgan
is engaging in what I would qualify as
escape behavior she was captured by the
dolphinarium
Hardwick in 2010 so this March our sixth
year in captivity the heart of what
dolphinarium in it's a Dutch dolphin
area and worked with SeaWorld to kind of
launder her to the Laurel Park a because
they were not allowed to bring her back
to the United States due to European law
so Cyril owns her and she was inserted
into this social group with five other
whales that she doesn't get along with
and at least according to the video it
looked like she jumped up onto that
stage area as a way to get away from the
other whales that was either before or
after a show and that's why people were
walking through the stadium and that's
how the footage was collected and you
can see she's just sitting up there and
a couple other whales swim by and take a
look at her as she's beached herself up
there I think that was a way for her to
prevent from getting beat up further is
that what's happening I mean what
happens as far as orcas are concerned
they do pick on the weakest yeah so
Morgan was brought in as an outsider so
to speak those other whales already knew
each other so they already had their own
pod Morgan's natal pod I think's of a
Norwegian pod called pod P is known and
she was actually collected she wasn't
saved that the dolphinarium brought her
in for rehabilitation and then Cyril got
involved and moved her
Loro Parque once she got inserted into
that other social group there was a lot
of social strife and that's what that
behavior is is her escaping getting beat
up there's a great paper written by dr.
Ingrid Visser and Matthew Matthew
Spiegel an attorney that was submitted
to the European Commission and the
United States Marine Mammal Commission
that talks about it's called the white
paper on whale laundering and there's
more information at the free Morgan
foundation that talks about how this
whale is being kept at Laurel Park a
illegally and how it's been sanctioned
by the court system essentially but yeah
she's avoiding getting beat up
she lives with Tito and four other
serial wells
Tito of courses infamous for killing
Alexis Martinez in 2009 and I feel sorry
for Morgan her teeth have been damaged
because of captivity you see her banging
her head on another video against a
steel gate and this is also how they
break their teeth by doing a behavior
called jaw popping so everything we're
seeing from Morgan shows us an unhappy
whale and her jumping up onto that
platform it is not a good sign it means
she's trying to get away from the others
in my opinion what can be done to help
her well there's a big push to get
Morgan reunited with her natal pod and
like I said people should check out the
free Morgan Foundation an NGO a
nonprofit trying to get her back into
her natal waters perhaps in an oceanic
sea pen and get her away from these
animals that are addressing forward sir
that would be my recommendation I know
that the Laurel Park a where she lives
right now are claiming that she has a
hearing deficit and that has not been
proven by an independent scientist so
I'm not sure if that's even true but
there's a big question about who truly
owns Morgan SeaWorld list Morgan on her
on their asset sheet and on their
stockholders report but it's really not
clear who owns her so I think that's a
bigger question that the European
Commission needs to answer and also
Laurel Park a and Cyril need to answer
as well because this animal being felt
there in my opinion illegally now just
well we've got you the documentary that
you made blackfish we're going to be
able to see it here in the
okay shortly don't we pardon me yeah it
showed yesterday on BBC and I was amazed
at how many people reached out to me via
Twitter it's really taken hold in the UK
and it's become a global movement
there's a benefit not a benefit concert
an awareness-raising concert in
Hollywood occurring on July 1st with
Jeff Beal the guy that wrote the score
for blackfish and we're gonna try to
raise some attention for the whales in
captivity including tilt them who
amazingly as so is still alive in Cyril
de Bourgh land oh right now okay quite
an impact its had on SeaWorld hasn't it
that your documentary you know that
they're no longer riding high like they
were previously and suddenly I suppose
suddenly people are starting to realize
that this is not an acceptable whale
way rather to keep these orcas to keep
these whales they shouldn't be in these
tiny pens in captivity where they're
basically going mad hey I'm happy to
hear you say that yeah blackfish has
been seen by a 65 to 150 million people
globally and it's still being shown on
BBC CNN Netflix iTunes and yeah it's had
a great impact I think it's created a
tipping point where keeping animals in
captivity something that UK has known
for a long time
is now becoming less palatable to people
in the United States and all over the
world unfortunately you still have
people in the Far East including China
the Middle East and Russia that are
trying to boost up their captivity
situation the Russian fishermen are now
collecting killer whales for parts in
China so I'm hoping that the tidal wave
that was created by blackfish will
continue into these Eastern markets and
the educational process that goes along
with it and I certainly hope so Jeffrey
good to talk to you thanks for
continuing to raise awareness and join
us again soon thank you oh right there
you too thank you very much